How do you feel about sauna therapy or infrared sunas if one has a
Malgum fillings? I have read
That detoxing in a sauna causes the mercury to leach and re-deposit deeper into the body
such as the organs. Can you come into this place?
I have not heard that so I don't think that
that heat in a sauna is going to cause you to leach
mercury from your Malgum fillings. I do know that heat like
your much worse position
drinking coffee with a Malgum fillings. If you have silver fillings
mercury fillings you're about to say you're drinking hot beverages
there's actually I think if I haven't taken it down
I've ever seen a video on YouTube where they actually had a tooth that was removed
and put hot water on it like hot coffee or hot tea
and then you could see the mercury gas up by and off of that fillings.
Pretty amazing and kind of scary. We shouldn't have mercury fillings in our mouth
and I know it's not always cost available for a person to have them removed
and we've had patients where the mercury is so embedded in every one of their teeth
and literally just have to have all their teeth pulled.
So it's very unfortunate what the quote-unquote modern dentistry has done to people
over the last few decades especially with the mercury fillings.
But I would question whether what you read about the sauna is actually true.
If you're doing a sauna I mean how would you measure that?
So if you measured a person's urine output of mercury
and you did a sauna and the urine output of mercury was elevated after a sauna
I would still say that I'm just guessing but I don't think physiologically that's coming from your teeth.
It's probably because of the heat and your sweating and your detoxing
because of the sauna you're probably expelled mercury out of the tissues and out of the cells.
So I would think that would be a good thing.
So otherwise how would you measure the sauna deep-positive mercury elsewhere?
I think that I'd be careful with mercury fillings.
First of all I can set hot beverages and things like that but how do you get around that?
You got to get your mercury fillings removed.
The other thing I'd be careful about is using really strong key layers.
And you should be careful about using really strong key layers if you have metal implants too.
Like nickel implants from a broken bowl or something like that.
Titanium, at least in my experience, has been people haven't had as much reaction to titanium.
So there are some people that have had reactions to titanium.
But mercury fillings are bad.
Yes, it's really a tough call.
I don't think sauna is going to make it worse.
Certainly you could try to prevent that if you think that that is an issue with you by doing more mild key layers.
And supporting your liver detox pathways, the benefit of the sauna is to help support detoxification through your skin.
So it takes some pressure off your liver and your kidneys.
So I don't think from a physiological standpoint it's going to draw your mercury from your teeth.